what is up guys my name is jonah and
welcome to episode 4.5
of 3d java game programming okay
um yeah this is sort of like a bonus
sort of episode where i
um really wanted to sort of focus on one
thing it's going to be a really short
video
and that is the way that this works
because um i don't feel that i explained
it well
and you know i've got messages saying um
could you explain it better
so um i think that the best way to
explain this is to actually demonstrate
so
um this is sort of what we had
and um the way that it renders the way
that it draws how does all this code
work
okay um the best way i think to explain
it is to simply add
you know system.out.printline into this
for loop
um in the render class print line and
we're just going to print
x um plus
x plus and i'll explain this in a minute
why plus y
okay so what what it's doing is it's
printing like
a string of text says x and it's
printing the x
variable uh so what you can see
is if i go into the console and i run
this
save it okay let's
exit out of this and let's sort of and
enlarge this console and take a look at
this
um and we'll also take a look at
paint.net
because paint.net is fast becoming my
favorite way to explain pixels to people
with this little grid thing the grid is
awesome okay
so we can say that you know at y when y
is 108 it's creating all these x values
so say that this
um say that this pixel
is number 108 down yeah for each 108
it's creating the entire range
of all these pixels across x and it will
stop
at 255. well it's technically 256.
if we saw if we oh we don't have that
but you can see that it starts at 0.1
because that's the way the java works
so yeah it's printing 256 because 256
is the amount that we've specified in
our screen
class so 256 basically fills up
this y value because it's render.height
so yeah that's that's how it works i
hope that this will sort of help you
explain
um more things and you know when y when
the y pixel
number is 109 it will render all of the
x pixels across so it's effectively
rendering
um in lines like this you know it'll
render this one first
then it'll go on to this one then it
will render this one
and so on and so forth so it's running
it's rendering that way across the
screen um hopefully those sound effects
helps you guys out
okay so that's a really quick episode um
don't worry episode five
where we actually move on to animating
stuff animating the pixels and i'll
actually
actually fix a lot of bugs as well
because i've already recorded episode
five
um that will that will be up today
that'll be that that will be up a few
hours after this video so don't worry
you're still getting a full episode
today i just really wanted to put this
in okay see you guys later
bye
you